vous savez que j'aime l'amour et ce soir
on a un invité mystère on a un invité
mystère aujourd'hui il s'est invité
mystère à une grande annonce à faire
acquis
ce qui parle là au fond c'est vous qui
avez dia qui a nom si nicole et claude
il va paraître en ombres chinoises et on
va écouter l'invité mystère
bonsoir invité mystère bonsoir conquis
bon soir invité mystère bonsoir voila
bonsoir invité mystère voilà apparemment
elle n'est pas passée chez le coiffeur
elle n'a pas donné beaucoup cette nuit
bon déjà on sait que c'est peut-être doc
gynéco les chéris il a quelque chose à
nous dire qu'est-ce qui se passe j'ai un
message à faire passer à quelqu'un dans
le public bien alors je vais demander à
tout public de se lever public levez
vous mais non on va droit levé la main
droite
dit je jure cracher sur la personne à
côté de wade et de jure tout le public
élevé invité mystère
est ce que cette annonce concerne un
homme ou une femme est une femme tuée
demandez donc à tous les hommes de
s'asseoir alors c'est qui est vicié près
dans ces qui est est ce que cette
annonce s'adresse à une femme qui a des
enfants
oui je demande à toutes les femmes qui
n'ont pas d'enfant de s'asseoir et
toutes les femmes qui n'ont pas d'enfant
de s'asseoir merci est ce que cette
femme habite en ile de france
non non tu as demandé à toutes les
femmes qui n'habite pas en ile de france
fac habite en ile-de-france d'ailleurs
de s'asseoir c'est con cette question
est-ce que son prénom commence par une
voyelle non non je n'en ai donc tu as
toutes les âneries mais 10,2 avec les
olives olives aux livres les isabelle de
s'asseoir là donc son prénom commence
par une console wii christine là je sens
un truc ce que je suis également
mentalist vous dit si je me trompe
est-ce que son prénom commence par un
vie oui comme diva gel bien sûr donc si
vous aimez prénom qui commence par un
vais rester debout
alors
une autre il n'y en a qu'une venez venez
me rejoindre
hélas
venez près de moi je n'attendais à toi
d'étonner est ce qu'on peut avoir un
micro s'il vous plaît c'est bon j'en ai
un
c'est bon je fais tout tout seul non
même pas c'est bon je démarrais cette
émission il est personne y avait trois
lumières et on est il me fallait donc
vous avez un prénom commence par un avis
quel est votre prénom valérie valérie
oui j'en connais une chute d'eau
mauvaise solution et valérie merci
d'être là derrière fait quoi dans la vie
pour l'instant plus rien vous avez quel
âge 34 ans nous a donné avec vos enfants
oui c'est qu'à cielo là c'est sa maison
qu'elle a raison car cet ennemi et
quatre ans cet ennemi 80 alors valérie
merci d'être là ce soir
pourquoi vous êtes là ce soir prouve que
dans le public un moment brouillés on va
dit plein de choses et là aux dernières
nouvelles j'avais des places vip pour
venir dans public ouais
[Applaudissements]
ça
oui mais attention c'est bien foutu de
vote est-ce que vous avez une idée de
qui peut être l'invité mystère derrière
comme ça oui j'imagine wesh peut
imaginer que ce métier c'est le papa de
wish i c'est pas beau fixe après comment
pascal pascal équipe complètement mais
qui est complètement fou gbagbo sait que
c'est pascal qui est complètement faux
ouais en tout cas il a l'air très bien
quoi finir penser que c'est pascal
donnais prédit pascal oui
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
y'a pas k naan qui s'appelle martin donc
c'est peut-être pas pascal pascal va
venir nous rejoindre ce que pascal va
arriver de là il a apparemment non il va
la vie de pascal
[Musique]
la voix
pascal et pascal mais rien à vous aviez
mis une perruque mois oui d'accord tu
voulais c'est ce micro path calme a
quelque chose à vous dire ce soir
c'est le papier mon amour notre présence
ici n'est pas un hasard comme touche pas
à mon poste
notre histoire à 10 ans et notre
sincérité
l'un envers l'autre notre amour et nos
d'arc à son autre force de notre amour
tu as donné la vie à nos deux princesses
elles remplissent nos coeurs de bonheur
à chaque instant et elles sont très
fiers de leur maman d'amour c'est le
seul endroit pour moi où je pouvais
immortaliser ce moment je prends un
témoin baba et les téléspectateurs pour
te dire à quel point je tiens à toi
valérie je t'aime
oh la la la la
[Applaudissements]
je pourrais pas garder alors au milieu
mais franchement c'est un magnifique
moment et il est franchement il a du
courage c'est nous qui l'avons fait
qu'un mariage ça coûte très cher c'est
pourquoi j'ai décidé de vous offrir la
bague de fiançailles ce soir je vous le
dis je vous propose aussi de vous offrir
les alliances pour le mariage soit bien
vous allez donc choisir les alliances
non le voilà que vous voulez au salon de
l'alliance de paris 2002 toulouse où
vous voulez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'adore j'adore les mariages mais les
mariages naturiste est pas pour moi je
vous le dis donc c'est quand même plus
sympa d'être bien habillé pour un
mariage
alors on a décidé de vous offrir aussi
le costume pour vous pascal et l'as rome
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
allez
mecheri vous fait pas dans la vie je
suis chargé clientèle d'accord où ça
chez l'écureuil
je connais une bonne dose de losail vous
aimez bien les yeux que les eaux
turquoises des plages paradisiaques chez
moi je déteste
oui parce que on vous offre un
magnifique voyage de noces
[Applaudissements]
villa ou papillon vous allez voir la
pièce
nos graphiques innovants de votre bilan
massol y aura des matches tous les jours
tous les matches
et
mais c'est un autre cadeau une
destination incroyable à la thaïlande où
kate tout ça voilà c'est pour nous parce
que vous nous avez touché les cherry
hill il a été exceptionnel se portait
[Applaudissements]
l'équipe
merci monsieur a laissé mes chéris ça va
être contente pas bon ça franchement
[Applaudissements]
ce match